I see her first time she tried eight
months looks like that crush is still
going strong david dobrik and Madison
beer have sparked dating rumors after
the singer posted this cute take talk
[Music]
the video shows the two alone acting
silly together
Madison captioned it losing our minds
which couldn't be more true fans are
losing it are you looking for love are
you looking to get married anytime soon
again yeah this is it I mean this is
tonight is I'm going to find love here
one fan ships the friends tweeting david
dobrik and Madison beer please date and
someone is already thinking about their
future children writing your babies
would be beautiful David and Madison
were just hanging out earlier this month
we saw them on Instagram jamming out to
her new single good and good bye
and the twenty-year-olds is always
popping up on david's blogs on YouTube
heyo Madison holy Sh guys check this out
guess what this means like I guess three
seconds Madison was last link to
socialite Zakia I just love them like
anyone's thoughtful and that he'll do
something sometimes stuff that's so
thoughtful and not just like validates
love to me but in March 2019 she
seemingly confirmed their split on
Twitter writing singled Madison thrives
David has dated YouTube personality Lysa
co-chief but they broke up in 2018 he's
not going anywhere so suck on that
future girlfriend the 23 year old has
also been rumored to date as assistant
Natalie
but he said to record straight with et
at the 2019 Streamy Awards what's the
craziest piece of log squad gossip that
we've heard this year that was just
completely false Jeff is not dating
Natalie neither am i so according to the
receipts
David and Madison are both single while
they haven't confirmed that they are
dating
we'll take their cute tick-tocks any day
[Music]